-Who are you?
-I lead a group of immortals.
An army, I guess.
Soldiers, fighters, like you.
Look...
you've got questions, kid.
I get it.
You want answers?
Get back in the car.
-That was a clip from
"The Old Guard,"
which is available
to stream now on Netflix.
Here's more of my conversation
with Charlize Theron.
Another really cool thing
about this film is --
obviously,
your co-star is a woman,
directed by a black woman.
And I believe the producers --
Three of the producers
were women, yourself included.
How was that experience?
Was it -- Did you feel the
difference being out there?
-Yeah. I mean, listen,
there's a sadness attached to
the fact that it feels so great,
because it does feel very
unusual, and that's not right.
We shouldn't have --
You know, when I look back on my
over-25-year career,
it's really sad how often --
how little I've experienced
with more women than men.
And so, you know,
it was really nice on this
to come on set and be
surrounded by women.
There was just a
different energy about it.
And, you know, just not women,
but, like,
really talented women.
Like, that is the other thing
that's always so crazy to me.
Like, it's not that hard to find
really talented women
in all departments --
not just in front of the camera,
but behind the camera.
And so, I --
You know, I think --
I really do think we have
to just --
We have to keep
the pressure on our industry
to kind of sustain
this kind of storytelling,
because it is really --
I almost swore -- F'ing awesome.
It really is.
-[ Laughs ] That's alright.
We would have happily beeped
that out for you.
That's the least we could do.
And this isn't
giving anything away,
but it is -- You know, again,
it's based on this comic
that tells a longer story.
It certainly seems set up
to tell more story.
And so that must be exciting
too, that, you know,
you have this very
female-forward action film
that is lined up to make more.
-Yeah. With another
female character,
which I'm really excited about.
The character of Quynh
is kind of teased in this.
She's Andy's
kind of right-hand person.
She's was --
The two of them were the first,
and there's obviously
a relationship there
that we didn't really explore
in this film.
So I'm excited, if we get the
chance to make another one,
to explore that, because then
we're just, you know,
adding another
female into the mix,
which I think will make it
really interesting.
-I do feel like
I'd like to finish --
The last time you were on the
show, we talked about
I think both of our favorite
female superhero, Rihanna.
And you and Rihanna
shared a publicist.
You told a really funny story
about her burning you
with a T-shirt of an e-mail
where the publicist
basically called her -- called
Rihanna her favorite client,
and then she sent that on
a T-shirt to you.
I then had the good fortune of
going day drinking with Rihanna.
And, yeah,
it's really good times
to have any connection to her
in the real world.
-She is -- she is everything.
I had the luxury of doing some
night drinking with her.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, out in London.
And it was some of
the best night drinking
I've ever done
in my entire life.
-Yeah, I should note
that we day-drank,
and then I went home to fall
asleep in my foyer.
And I got the sense
that that wasn't
the last drinking she did.
I got the sense that, like, the
most drinking I had done
in like years was just, like,
warm-up stretches for her.
[ Both laugh ]
So, I'm very jealous.
I'm very jealous that you
got the other half of it.
-She needs to be in
the next "Old Guard."
"Ri-Ri."
-Yeah.
There you go. There you go.
See? We put together
some casting, as well.
Charlize, I really do hope
the next time I see you,
it's in person.
Congrats on the film.
It's so much fun.
And I hope to see you soon.
-Thank you so much, Seth.
Nice to see you.
-Nice to see you, too.
-Next time, we can talk about
all the "Moby-Dick" stuff
in the background there.
-This is what I --
I'm at my in-laws's house,
so I can't choose decor.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
-That's all right.
[ Both laugh ]